hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be diving into the
claims made by instagram sensation
glucose goddess and look at the trend of
balancing blood sugar levels to lose
weight and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
general disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey as we will be discussing
weight loss and if you are not already
subscribed here hit that subscribe
button and follow me over on tiktok and
instagram abby's kitchen all right so
apparently you guys have a lot of
questions about this creator my dms have
been low-key raging with messages about
the self-proclaimed glucose goddess
jessie in chespae and i get it jessie's
posts and graphics are admittedly really
captivating and convincing her diet
suggestions seem almost magical and
surprisingly simple
things like eating food in a specific
order adding a single ingredient to keep
you in fat burning mode and tweaking
your breakfast to kiss your cravings
away some fishy going on here and she's
clearly made an impact considering she's
been on a very successful media tour to
promote her best-selling book glucose
revolution but do all of her claims
stack up to the science well before we
go too far i want to highlight that
blood sugar control is actually very
important this is not something that i'm
against or think of as like bs metabolic
disease is definitely on the rise and
according to the cdc more than one in
three americans have pre-diabetes and
one in ten have diabetes those are some
very significant numbers so i definitely
do support the cause what i don't like
though is the sensationalism and
misrepresentation of science to the
point of hysteria food fear and
obsession
so let me separate nutrition truth from
some really [ __ ] good marketing to
sell books exhibit a this statement
right here eighty percent of
non-diabetics are likely to experience
glucose spikes with everyday foods like
breakfast cereal i mean no wonder people
are feeling scared even folks who don't
really know anything about diabetes
probably know that glucose spikes sounds
like bad news bears so now you've got it
in your head that even if you're
metabolically healthy you're walking
around with like raging blood sugars
just from eating normal food this kind
of statement is known as a hook
it draws you in because you now feel
like this is personal like it's about
you however this very specific claim
which she actually takes the liberty to
randomly bump up to 90 in an instagram
post isn't exactly the whole truth it
comes from a study that she cites which
found that a standardized diet of corn
flakes and milk caused glucose elevation
in the pre-diabetic range in about 80
percent of the participants now besides
the fact that the study was a small one
and not representative of the entire
general population let's pretend for a
minute that the statement is true if
this is the case we now need to ask two
important questions one do blood sugar
spikes really happen in healthy
non-diabetic people and two are glucose
spikes actually a super bad thing now to
the first point if you are a healthy
person metabolically your blood sugar
levels are controlled by a variety of
hormonal feedback mechanisms mostly
involving insulin and glucagon these
little puppies run a very tight ship and
prevent your blood sugar levels from
rising too quickly or dropping too low
and this is really important because
chronically high blood sugar levels are
very dangerous for really anyone but
this concept was actually put to the
test by the all you can eat pizza study
that i spoke to in my insulin video so
it basically showed that even when
healthy men ate so much pizza that they
thought they were gonna burst their
blood sugar levels never really rose
above a certain point reiterating that
in healthy folks without diabetes our
blood sugar levels are very tightly
regulated regardless of how much or what
we eat now this study is also not
exactly representative and it's
obviously an extreme example i mean
eating as much as you can possibly stuff
into your mouth is not exactly best
practice
but when we look at more moderate
studies that look at blood sugar levels
in free living people we see that 96 of
the time blood sugar levels remain
between 70 to 140 milligrams per
deciliter we also see that the median
fluctuation between readings known as
glucose variability is quite low in
healthy participants basically sitting
at 18.2 percent versus 26.1 percent in
people with diabetes this means that in
general the difference between the highs
and the lows in a healthy person is not
really all that much which is another
nod to our tight little glucose
relationship type type type so scary
blood sugar spikes are actually not that
common and if or when they do happen our
bodies jump in and remedy the situation
pretty quick but let's just say that you
did get a spike how bad would that
actually be well our girl glucose
goddess tells us that these spikes
mutate our dna leading to every wellness
influencer's favorite frenemy
inflammation which again is scary as
thankfully it's not the whole truth the
research suggests that for folks with
diabetes blood sugar spikes can be more
dramatic since the body's regulatory
system isn't really working optimally
now blood sugar spikes can actually
damage blood vessels and increase
inflammation through increasing
oxidative stress which is exactly what
jesse says and this is why folks with
diabetes take medication
insulin or follow dietary guidelines to
help temper those major spikes but
here's what her statement is missing
people with diabetes in the non-diabetic
population who have healthy working
pancreases not only are we not having
these dramatic spikes but there's really
little evidence to show that the small
variations that we do have is promoting
any chronic inflammation so to recap for
healthy non-diabetic folks blood sugar
spikes aren't generally a major problem
or danger but does this mean that we
don't need to worry about blood sugar
control at all
not so fast for those of us with healthy
blood sugar control mechanisms there are
still some benefits to paying attention
to how our food or activity affects our
blood sugar levels mainly that sustained
blood sugar levels can keep you feeling
satiated and energized longer reducing
the need for constant snacking and
making a calorie deficit and therefore
weight loss easier and this brings me to
exhibit b one of her signature hacks
food eating order so jessie basically
went viral when a video of her meal
order recommendation made its way across
mark hyman's ig basically jessie claims
that by eating your food in the right
order you can reduce the glucose spike
of the meal by 75
according to her
this means eating your vegetables first
protein and fat second and starches and
sugars last now according to the
research on jessie's website this hack
promotes simple weight loss primarily
because it lowers our blood glucose
spikes she then goes on to extrapolate
that this will translate into weight
loss because lower glucose spikes means
lower insulin spikes and she insists
that lowering insulin is the secret to
weight loss success she also quotes one
study suggesting that when 16 diabetic
patients ate their carbohydrate portion
of their meal 10 minutes after they had
their protein and fat levels of their
hunger hormone ghrelin seemed to decline
so let's break all this down number one
of all three studies that she quotes all
of them had very small sample sizes so
they're not exactly generalizable and
only one of these studies was conducted
using non-diabetic subjects none of the
studies focused on weight loss as a
primary outcome and in fact one study
found that weight loss was actually
similar between those with the fixed
meal order and those who kind of mixed
up their meals another study that did
focus on weight loss in the pre-diabetic
population found that people eating
their food in a specific meal order and
those who receive health guidance lost a
similar amount of weight over a six
month period so this suggests that some
guidance may be better than nothing but
not that meal order is directly related
or causing the weight loss two if you're
a regular stan here you now know that
insulin is not the big bad fat storage
hormone that everyone makes it out to be
i did a whole video on why lowering your
insulin isn't going to make or break
your weight loss a calorie deficit is if
we do see a benefit to a lower insulin
life on helping you tip the scales it's
largely because foods that are lower on
the glycemic index and therefore elicit
a lower insulin spike like vegetables
tend to keep us feeling fuller longer
for fewer calories which just makes
eating less a little easier you also
likely are not eating as often or as
much if fasting is part of your insulin
lowering plan fewer eating episodes
fewer calories in general and three
while the grail and study is super
interesting we definitely need more
research to clarify if these results can
be applied to different populations
because there are actually other studies
that show that meal order has no real
effect on ghrelin levels or perceived
fullness levels bottom line if you lose
weight by eating your food in a specific
order
it's not like your hormones are just
like
clicking into a magic place and presto
chango the fat's just going to melt away
it's just that we know that dietary fat
fiber and protein aka the hunger
crushing combo helps to slow down
gastric emptying and provide a more
sustained glucose response it also makes
you feel fuller for longer which again
we're back to that whole calorie deficit
thing interestingly a year or so ago i
actually dm'd jessie about this concept
and i asked her how deliberate she
thought you'd have to be to reap the
benefits of this approach now this was
before her book came out and she was
like hammering home her message with
lots of marketing savvy she basically
told me that if it makes sense in a meal
to like have a salad first for example
then great but if not she said you don't
need to like super stress over which
bite in a mixed meal comes first and
this is precisely my take home message
as well the benefits of dressing up
naked carbs for blood sugar control are
well documented but stressing over the
first bite in your primavera penne being
like a floret of broccoli instead of
your chicken or your pasta may actually
do more harm than good we know that our
cortisol levels can be heightened in
times of stress so things like strict
dieting or following very rigid food
rules and excess cortisol is also not
good for our blood sugar control or
insulin sensitivity and since it seems
like jessie herself acknowledged this in
her message to me before her book was
released i can't help but wonder if this
hack has been overhyped and that brings
me to exhibit c her secret ingredient to
fat loss now according to jessie
we can eat dessert without getting
kicked out of fat burning mode simply by
adding a standard pantry staple vinegar
now if we ignore the fact this verbiage
is problematic from a relationship with
food stamps does vinegar really put you
in or keep you in a fat burning zone
danger
well jesse's evidence of this is
grounded in some legitimate science so
vinegar does seem to have a blood
glucose lowering effect possibly because
it's thought to delay gastric emptying
now it then follows the thinking that we
already unpacked that if your blood
sugar is controlled your insulin is
lowered and you can miraculously lose
weight as is often the case with a lot
of like diet experts this all seems to
have originated from a shred of science
that gets stretched
a little thin the research we have on
the benefits of vinegar for insulin and
glucose suppression shows that although
using vinegar does seem to have a
beneficial effect on blood glucose
levels in the short term i.e day-to-day
over the long term that is like chronic
use over a month or more
the research is more sparse on the
effects in a healthy population where we
do see some long-term benefits however
is in patients with glucose
abnormalities like diabetes and pcos
possibly through an effect on insulin
sensitivity and you also have to take
quite a lot of it like up to two
tablespoons before meals unless you
don't mind carrying around a handbag
with like a bottle of vinegar in it at
all times this feels
somewhat impractical regularly drinking
vinegar can also result in side effects
like tooth enamel erosion and worsening
of existing gastritis now thankfully
jesse does recommend that you dilute the
vinegar with water and drink it through
a straw to reduce the effects but i do
feel like this kind of just like adds to
its impracticality honestly i'm not
convinced that the inconvenience is
worth it for folks with normally
functioning pancreases nor do i think
it's accurate to say that a shot of
vinegar is going to magically keep you
in that burning zone while you eat
dessert and finally let's talk about her
hot take on breakfast so a final
take-home tip that we see peppered
throughout jesse's online content and
book is that a simple small change to
your morning breakfast will unlock your
energy and decrease your cravings that
is just swap your sweet breakfast for
something savory i think the point of
this tip is to like acutely say that we
should try not to have donuts danishes
and frappuccinos for breakfast and yeah
like that makes sense those foods are
all rich in simple carbs and low in the
fiber protein and fat that we just
established helps to keep us full and
energized for longer and even though a
healthy individual's blood glucose
levels are tightly controlled to prevent
legitimate dangerous highs and lows
research suggests that minor
fluctuations can still make us feel a
bit blah so what she could have said was
a krispy kreme for breakfast isn't great
for your blood sugars but that doesn't
sound like a sexy sound bite and you
know what we do need to sometimes
simplify nutrition it's complicated as
but not when the context that we lose
helps to make good nutrition more
attainable in real life folks a healthy
diet for blood sugar management is not
about the flavor or taste of your food
it's not even about a single food it's
about the nutritional content of a
complete meal or many meals over time
and to call out all sweet foods as being
bad for your blood sugars means
eliminating a lot of super nutritious
staples that we really love think about
things like oatmeal with berries and nut
butter greek yogurt peaches and almonds
or a smoothie with protein powder fruit
nuts and milk for a lot of us breakfast
just is not breakfast if it's not sweet
so being relegated to eggs and avocado
might not be such a small change for a
lot of people and even if we were able
to cut out all of our favorite sweet
breakfast options making them savory
doesn't automatically result in a
healthier morning meal i could think of
lots of unbalanced savory breakfast like
white bagels toast english muffins or
breakfast hash browns none of which are
going to do our blood sugars any major
favors so while i appreciate that this
might be an easy to remember kind of
like rule of thumb i think we can all
agree that again it's not the magic
bullet to weight loss or good health so
in conclusion i don't think that glucose
goddess is blatantly wrong about
anything here i just think that she's
found a hook that seems to captivate
people's attention and gotten a little
too aggressive on the marketing she's
turned a small bit of science
particularly in a specific population
into sensationalism and in some cases
fear-mongering and i strongly just do
not believe that it serves the public
well the real key to blood sugar
management and by extension weight loss
isn't a big secret that's being gate
kept by a biochemist turn born
communicator as she's been described you
don't need to obsess over eating a piece
of broccoli before a piece of pasta or
carting a bottle of vinegar around in
your purse or swearing off oatmeal just
because it's sweet it simply comes down
to nutrition 101 moderation balance
variety it's a super unsexy approach
that let's be real doesn't sell out diet
books but honestly
it actually does work so if you are
truly struggling with your blood sugar
control please speak to a registered
dietitian and a doctor about your unique
health care needs chances are you can
still have a sweet breakfast if that's
your thing and on that note that's all
that i have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]